Slavia you just finish your studies
congratulations again now gap stop just
had finished his studies as engineer
Eastern 23 but his real education only
starts when he goes to the Falls for
three weeks and he stays there for seven
years so to Philadelphia and all of you
universities are supposed to be a place
for building is that your experience I'm
very curious about that and if not where
have you found your own magic mountain
but after you first yeah I must say I
was very lucky to meet serve several
great teachers already in high school
but then also at university for example
my teacher in philosophy of law he
invited some students who were mostly
six of us over to his home his own
library and he was scattering us around
like some deal was he's offering the
wine we bring the foods and then with
his guests as long as it takes right so
we mostly started at 8:00 in the evening
and then we I don't know discussed about
freewill or any other you know fine
esophageal issue and that was I mean I
learned so much about him and his
worldview but also he was of course and
challenging us a lot about the broader
world outside of academics definitely so
I for me that was an extraordinary
academic experience so I would I want to
be thankful but then on the other hand
of course what I missed in most of the
seminars was like debate you know like
and a political debate as well because
that what I was surprised about I mean
the most political activism I
experienced at university was about that
and all the race of tuition fees okay I
mean it's an issue of course I'm not
saying this but you know that's not what
this happening outside there in the
world so that's why also I co-founded
this movement because it was not like
academic academia wasn't really a place
where I felt there was a real discussion
going on it was very difficult I'm
talking about Italy I said answer
language at university for me it was
very difficult to be a woman
I remember that one day my professor a
very old professor told me you are too
blonde to be taken seriously and I must
being a rebel and the day before I see
you tomorrow okay the next day I I
really came with dark hair and I asked
me I asked him is it all right now can I
talk can I ever the same respect as my
cooking and after my book this is really
funny
almost alpha professor in Italy doesn't
matter affair of MA engineer or classic
language claimed that they'd be my
professor I won't go back
making Marcus I did find I just
graduated from Penn and a couple of
months ago and I I felt blessed to have
been there for four years and was able
to read like basically whatever I wanted
for the entire time it wasn't easy it
wasn't like consistent with the whole
culture of the university to study
history intellectual history for four
years there's a lot of pressure to like
to consider it a pre-professional
experience and to basically get out of
it whatever you need to in order to make
the most money you can I thought that
was in throw an typologically
interesting and that was part of my
education so reading books was part of
my education and meeting people who were
only in university in order to make a
lot of money was part of my education
people who had never read you know an
entire book in like were proud that they
got through college without reading
books that was part of my education
meeting people like that I really
realized the importance of collaboration
of working with others and in both the
world of music you know you become a
better musician a better artist when you
open yourself up to collaborating with
this many different kinds of musicians
and artists as possible but and also in
when I was 15 and I learned about
climate change
that was that was where a huge turning
point in my life where I realized that
this was no matter what else I was
interested in I had to follow this path
and do whatever I could in this crisis
and in in the world of climate action
and in activism it's through that all of
those collaborations that I really have
I think learned the most just from other
people and people from all walks of life
and what they're doing what their ideas
are you said what was your magic
mountain education I think it was really
at home with my family I think
especially the best thing you can give
your child is the gift of reading and
exploration because of literature
because then they can just either have
an autonomy and it goes back to what
they were saying earlier in the first
panel about empathy that reading is
magical because you can actually imagine
what it's like to be somebody else and
most of us experience the world through
our own interpretive framework which is
about our identity about who we happen
to be positionality and reading enables
you to come out of that and to be
somebody else to be somewhere else so I
really I think you know really the the
best thing we can do is is to read and
to also not expect the formal education
system to give us everything because I
very much approached University as just
an opportunity to do other things like
you then actually going to my classes I
mean I went to enough to actually do
well but I very much you know enjoyed
reading around my subject and also
actually engaging in activism and I
found that a lot of you know going back
to your point yeah a lot of the
education happens outside the classroom
it's about building knowledge together
and I think that's what I learned my
family is that
okay you have the text even when it
comes to religion you have Revelation
which is something fixed in time but
actually when it comes to truth it's
something that's constructed continually
and through interaction exchange so
University for me is a way of building
meaning with other people as well
through student activism I was active in
my student union I was active in fair
trade movement and in social work so
it's really about I think the university
gives you a space and it's not too young
people to know how to use that space and
to be active and not passive learners of
recipients of knowledge
you